elon musk trolls jeff pesos maybe bring
up the tweet kai
for losing nasa nasa contract to spacex
and he says can't get it up this is a
immediate story it's not my rockets
right yeah
earlier this month that's announced that
it's uh has chosen ilama
spacex to bring its next astronauts to
the moon perhaps as early as 2024 the
contract is valued at 2.9 billion
dollars that didn't sit well with blue
origin the aerospace company
founded by bezos the blue origin and a
third bidder called
dynetics uh filled protest not
dianetics dynetics field a file protest
with the government
accountability office claiming nasa
changed the bidding rules
late in the process news of the filing
seemed to
delight musk who took to twitter on
monday to
channel his inner middle schooler by
saying bezos and blue origin can't
get it up lol such schoolyard humorous
old hat for musk who last
june tweeted to inform his tens of
millions of followers that it was 69
days after 4
20. that is elon musk for you there's a
tweet by the way they took it down or no
where's the tweet oh my gosh
adam thoughts well you're like i've been
very vocal on uh
on what elon musk likes to do in his
sexual life and you know banging aliens
and all that kind of stuff is kind of
his fantasy land
but he's a giant look everyone kind of
you can kind of go different directions
he's a child at heart
clearly he's a dreamer he's a visionary
i love that yeah yeah i love being a
child
he's an eighth grader you can't get it
up giggity yeah like
what billionaire 100 million dollars
talking [ __ ] to a fellow
richest man in the world again so polly
can't get it
tweet that out got him 69 420 like
what this is the ceo of the one of the
biggest companies in the world
so i think what we are seeing here is
this is watching
mj and lebron go at it in their prime
bezos and muzzles like everyone says
who's better looking
though who's mj though oh well i mean
uh bezos is older and he's been doing it
longer so i guess
in this situation and he is richer
ninety percent of this goes back and
forth though so you kind of gotta go
stop it so you're saying that that musk
is outside
why
oh my gosh so you're saying that okay
i'm just i don't know
pat i don't know if elon musk is mj or
lebron i don't know so you're
what i'm saying is we're watching two
titans go out and i think it's great
you know who's winning today us the
world is winning we're waiting
man this is great to see 69 420 speaking
of 420 what are your thoughts on this
apollo
yeah when i'm looking at this i'm back
to your analogy
i think that currently right now i think
musk is mj on the rise because he's
battling he's battling uh uh bezos
here's why because when mj was coming up
he was a great scorer and then he was
great this uh aspect and then he
it improved another ass defense uh you
know a three-point shot all these
different things he had to have
a solid mid-range game uh mj but when
you look when you're looking at uh uh
musk and uh these guys going back at it
did you just file something with the sec
like a couple months ago
talking about he was the new titleist
master of the universe
yeah yeah coin or master of coins that's
what entrepreneurship is all about you
should be having fun you should be
playing loose
things are so tight intense and put so
much pressure on your shoulder hey why
not
pat so do you agree with my mj lebron
yeah i look uh here's what i think man i
think you know as much as twitter has
divided america twitter is also
entertain america
always there's a show to watch on
twitter because twitter take take
twitter out
take twitter out what do you when where
do you go and say that
take social media out where do you go
and say can't get it out right like
how long after that news came out do you
think elon musk tweeted tweeted can't
get it up
one hour 30 minutes later 20 minutes
later that's the advantage
that's the positive side of social media
where you get to say
what's on your mind right now and then
maybe the day later like i probably
shouldn't have said that but
you get to see that part of immediate
reaction for someone
to me it's entertaining and to me it's
competition going back and forth kai's
trying to two and a half hours later
two and a half hours later after
announcement was okay the tweet was
posted at five
yeah and he responded that's what i'm
saying i mean that's the part that's
kind of like
you know if you didn't have it that way
you'd have to wait two days elon musk
makes a and
your interview with uh you know such and
such magazine and he said that this
person can't get it up you know it's
like
now it's like immediate here's what he
says this guy can't get it up and we can
send the box of viagra too
you know cialis or viagra to bezos
would be funny would be funny is if
bazels go to work this week
[Laughter]
you know what i would do if i was in
that situation if i'm bigger or cialis i
would get into that topic i would get in
and i would say
that's why we're here as is
a new spokesperson you should jump in
there says
mr bezos we're here to help
that would get so much like story to
viagra and cialis but you know to do
that there's regulations fda's i'm sure
there's something
behind it as well so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye